[Music]
Markovski brothers do it again you guys
you pulled out all the stops for the our
weight or you've got the sound effects
what are we gonna experience on this
tour My Big Fat Greek Wedding meets the
Rat Pack needs
hints of Magic Mike in this it's been
beyond any of my expectations it's been
insanity in here I just can't wait to
get out there
max Pete in Val they're sharing such
personal stories of their own
there's dances are so comedic and
hilarious it's a family affair for max
Val and Peeta along with baby shy the
trio is hitting the road with their
confidential tour et was exclusively
invited inside their la rehearsals where
it was clear art is 100% imitating light
is it I guess a good creative challenge
to think about your love story and think
about how you want to tell it through
choreography I don't think I've fully
gone back to what has happened yet
throughout the breakup and stuff like
that we broke up for you it's gonna be a
process of I mean crazy emotion I'm sure
when I go there it's gonna be very
intense and to relive all of that stuff
the reality is that you know end result
is beautiful not necessarily you know
everything in leading up to it was
beautiful is it gonna be cheerful
probably yeah
[Music]
max posted a photo of you with Mandy
Moore and he said that this number is
gonna make you cry like 50 times yeah
she did our wedding number so it's just
bringing back all the fields it's like a
contemporary way of describing like us
walking down and you know like having
that first dance together and yeah it's
magical somebody like Mandy she knows us
through and through she was at the
wedding
the end result is just so heartfelt it's
like you know I'm not being
choreographed here the steps do this but
it's it's like this is the story this is
how and it's just a brilliant
storytelling
[Music]
we're gonna get a lot of Max & peeta
love story yeah are we gonna get any Val
love story on stage yeah yeah I mean Val
Val love stories in the show how has
Jenna influenced your creativity she's
been my muse poor for lack of a better
word I mean she's been my partner in
crime
everything that I've created on Dancing
with the Stars I'd say in the last four
years on the show she's played a huge
part of she's been there for me for a
long time is there a number that we're
gonna either see her pop up in or a
number dedicated to her if you know me
if you know ours our story you will
definitely get the reference maybe
there's gonna be like I don't know like
a hologram you guys get really intimate
with your fans you offer this package
where they can like sip champagne and
hang out with you in your dressing room
or apple cider it's just a nice way of
kind of bonding with them and sipping
champagne and just chatting before we go
live are there any funny weird crazy
experiences that stand out I've signed a
boob Wow
PETA post Peter 3 Peter not an
inappropriate part of the boot just just
the top part sometime later I think I
saw the same person with the tat tat it
over signature so okay if you are the
lucky fan who's Google sign and then
tattooed by the closest social media
yeah send me in the paper
that deserves a free ticket to the
confidential tour yeah oh oh yeah you
can get him to sign the other one
[Music]
[Applause]